now without further ado making fun of
don lemon yes
here's the story from fox news don lemon
continues to lose
viewers even after rebranding cnn show
desperate publicity stunt the cnn anchor
has lost
a whopping 77 of viewers since the first
week in january
now when i heard the story you may have
you may have heard this
don lemon apparently made some
announcement that he was
grateful for all his years at cnn and he
was going to be you know
changes were coming and everybody was
tweeting i saw everybody tweeting don
lemon's quitting it's over the show's
done
his ratings have dropped so dramatically
surely they have fired the man
turns out it was a publicity stunt where
he's like
here's what he look as a quote i
appreciate all the years of cnn tonight
with don lemon
but changes are coming and i will fill
you in and then
all they did was they changed the name
of his show
from cnn tonight with don lemon to don
lemon tonight
that's it same time slot same times a
lot same everything same everything
i mean honestly isn't there a point
where
cnn just recognizes that they're
basically parody
at this point this is something that
someone on our this is like a babylon b
article this is something someone on our
side would spoof
say you know this is how ridiculous cnn
we don't have to worry about that
because cnn is actually
they're doing it themselves didn't
babylon b write an article saying that
like cnn was beating them at their own
game
it was something like that no but that's
what's what what's really funny about
the satirical articles like babylon b
the onion writes really over the top
nonsense
like one of my favorites is uh stress of
the presidency ages joe biden 10 years
and it's a corpse just like a scout like
a mummified corpse
because he's already almost 80 years old
that's that's a that's real dark humor
but
it's very silly right babylon b has
their silly articles but they'll also
write things like
cnn you know beats wins award to beat
babylon be at parity or something
and the funny thing about babylon b is
it's it's a higher brow humor oh yeah
and people fall for i think i want to
try and find it if there's that uh let's
see if i can find the babylon b
cnn competition i don't even know what
to look for but i'm pretty sure they did
that
well and you know there's been all of
this like pushback against babylon b
people saying like oh you know
politifact rating that oh this is not
true you know this is a debunked thing
i mean it should speak about the state
of the modern democratic party and the
left
that people easily confuse obvious
parity
with the actual policies of the left you
know like
to to be fair i've seen people confuse
uh like the onion for real news too
yeah but babylon b is is very political
and there are a lot of people who think
who fall for it
so here's the article in major deal the
babylon b
purchases competing satire site cnn
and it shows the babylon b logo next to
the cnn logo
so good this is this is beyond parody i
don't know if we can
maybe i can play this let's let's try
and play it
there we go earlier i told you i had an
announcement
and i do it's been really really great
this is the last night that we'll be cnn
tonight with don lemon
so i appreciate all the years of cnn
tonight with don lemon
but changes are coming and i will fill
you in
but until then i am very proud of my cnn
special about marvin gaye's
groundhog all right all right you get it
the dude was very obviously trying to
make it seem like he was quitting
right wow well it's good news
no and by the way like is was anybody
more disappointed that trump lost than
the executives at cnn
yeah they were they were hurt the worst
absolutely you know but they built their
entire
brand around we hate trump more than
anybody else
msnbc did as well so i just watched the
deep impact you ever see that movie
no have whitian's laughing no no i've
seen i've seen the clips from it
uh armageddon was clearly the better
movie so you do you know what twin films
is so like this is weird that happens
where
they keep they make two movies of the
same movie at the same time
so like a good example would be a bug's
life and like ants is this kind of like
when
in uh uh r b or hip hop in the 90s where
they did whoop there it is and then like
hoot there it is like the same thing
yeah something like that yeah okay
so they made armageddon ask you know a
bunch of guys got to go to an asteroid
blowed up
and they made deep impact batons got to
go to a comic con and then blow it up
uh in that movie because i don't lose my
train of thought
the main character works for msnbc and
she's trying to do a legitimate story
like the movie starts spoiler alerts for
those that haven't seen a 20 23 year old
movie
so she works for msnbc she thinks she's
got a story about the president having
an affair with a woman named ellie
msnbc investigative reporting
in the same story amazing right yeah
today
so but it was interesting because i'm i
i watched armageddon
which is this really silly movie where
these like oil rig guys go to an
asteroid it makes no sense but it's
it's it's ridiculous silliness deep
impact tries to be much more serious
we're like we got to go to this comment
and blow it up
and i'm like i'm watching the beginning
and i see this woman she's like i work
for msnbc and a camera guy comes out and
they're like we're going to get this
report on the president expose him
i'm like wow is that what msnbc used to
be right were they like real news at
some point i don't remember them being
no there was
there was a there was a time where msnbc
was kind of positioned
as the almost a right of center news
organization
like way back in the day wow yeah i know
like that's it seems amazing by the way
the reason why cnn's been hurt more than
msnbc
is because i hate both of them equally
but msnbc has leaned into
actually some kind of entertaining
personalities like i mean i think rachel
maddow's a buffoon
but she's good at her job when she cried
when the mueller report
she well she almost cried when the
mueller report was like
was bunk right like trump wasn't a
russian asset you could see her like
welling up like
well this is it that no
no they've they've got you know rachel
maddow they've got joy reid like i can't
believe that woman still
has a job they've leaned into these kind
of like bigger personalities
whereas cnn's got chris cuomo and don
lemon and brian stelter and essie cupp
i mean it's like you know i mean
obviously if you're gonna if you're a
a left winger and it's post-trump if
you're gonna watch
anything it seems like msnbc is gonna be
a little more entertaining to watch than
cnn you know what it feels like
could you imagine going to a circus like
imagine there's two circuses
and in one there's a bunch of clowns
going we are not clowns
do not laugh at us and you go on the
other one i'm like we're totally clowns
have a good time yeah
that's msnbc yes they like they're
totally 100
yeah cnn is trying to make you think
they're like imagine a bunch of clowns
wearing like suits
but they're still in their clown makeup
and they're trying to act like they're
doing reporting
you're like guys okay this doesn't work
well and it's like the contrast doesn't
work either
like you know they've got those people
like wolf blitzer and john king are
supposed to be like these hard news
people
and they're on a cr i mean essentially
like a crazy conspiracy
hoax filled television you know what i
mean like it's like it doesn't it
doesn't work meanwhile like
msnbc is going with joy reid like she's
just everybody knows she's not like
they're not even trying
you look at what what don lemon did with
that audio clip very
clearly making it seem like he was
quitting in a desperate bid
you know that bad happened i bet they
were like don your ratings are down
77 like nobody's watching and he was
like well maybe people don't know it's
my show
maybe people need to know it's don lemon
you're right let's change the name from
cnn tonight with don lemon to
don lemon tonight yeah like that's their
big play yep uh okay
that's you know okay i forgot where i
was going before but clearly the
strategy makes no sense
the ratings are in the gutter and that
was what they thought was going to
attract people
well i mean but again they built an
entire brand around
trump i mean no one was watching cnn
before trump you go back and you look at
the ratings pre-trump
cnn's ratings were absolutely in the in
the garbage i mean they were they were
absolutely terrible because
to their credit for a few years cnn
tried to be this place somewhere in
between fox
news and msnbc and they realize in an
increasingly
polarized society there was no room to
kind of be the middle guy
so instead they just went dove all in
you know into hating trump you mentioned
this we were talking about satire that
it says something when snopes needs to
constantly debunk the babylon bee
about cnn's type you know audience
here's what happens
tucker carlson his ratings went down for
sure
it still is it like three million or
whatever in the key demo he's still
i think he's in the high you know six
fig six figures
so everybody's ratings took a hit
literally everybody so for obvious
reasons i mean you had this massive
election
everybody's gonna go down but msnbc and
cnn went down
more than like all the other networks
more than all the youtube channels i
mean a lot of people on youtube and
podcasts are doing better
ratings are going up so what happened
was
tucker for instance he is he's the
highest rated because
for one i think he's a smart guy i think
he's a really good job and as for the
other cnn
personalities fox is like an oasis in a
desert
you can go to any one of these networks
nbc abc whatever and and hear the same
garbled nonsense one of my favorite
examples of how garbo the nonsense was
is during the the the
mueller no no no no no this is the
ukraine stuff gordon sandlin that's
his name right sondling yeah he had said
that trump said no quid pro quo but he
thinks trump wanted it
what did fox news say quote sandlin
quote no quid pro quo literally a quote
i can accept that whether you infer
something else from it every other
network
sondlin confirms quid pro quo so so
so fox is this oasis in the desert for
people they want to watch something they
know
cnn and msnbc leaned in as hard as they
could into building
a a network off of people who hate trump
that won't last once trump is gone it
says a lot about the two different
culture war
you know parent bubbles whatever they're
you know smaller bubbles are libertarian
conservative whatever versus like
leftist liberal
the the liberal voters only cared about
hating trump
and that's the only thing that kept them
together as a voting block and that
that's why
this honeymoon is going to be so quick
for joe biden because the sad reality
for him
is is there's no cohesive policy
like group behind him like whether you
love trump or hated trump
trump in 2017 when he got inaugurated
people knew what it was trump for
he was for building a wall you know he
was for negotiating new
trade deals he was for making america
great again
all of these things he was for biden
voters only cared about one thing
i hate trump and so now you're seeing
all these
internal divisions with the democratic
party over actual policy stuff
and realizing they have no cohesive
argument because their entire election
was predicated on simply hating trump
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you